Also was wir uns heute widmen werden ist folgendes, Windows stellt ganz gern, wobei ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher ob es Windows ist oder ob es einfach nur kack Windows Anwendungen sind,
z.B. wenn man Modern Warfare startet stellt sich die Anwendung immer auf 100% z.B. wenn
man Skype oder Teams verwendet stellt das laufend am Mikrofon rum, deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
wir basteln was, was man im Hintergrund laufen lassen kann und das Audio immer richtig einstellt,
also je nachdem wie man es haben will. Ich habe mir schon kurz ein bisschen was angeguckt vorher
wie das unter Windows geht und ich kann euch sagen es ist nicht normal, es ist absolut der
übelste Api Wirrwahl, eines der schlimmsten die ich bisher gesehen habe unter Windows Alter.
Das ganze nennt sich Windows Core Audio Library, das hört sich so an als hat es schon mal einen
ganz guten Namen, es hat übrigens nichts mit UWP oder so zu tun, auch wenn es ein bisschen
danach klingt, es gibt es erst seit Windows 7, es ist auch egal, Windows 7 ist das kleinste
was wir supporten, das reicht schon, aber es ist eklig, es ist echt eklig, das kann ich
euch sagen. Gummi Bear Games hat Subscribed, 2 Monate, Dankeschön, excellent Subscription,
huge. Mein Emote Board funktioniert nicht, Moment, ich habe die Auflösung falsch eingestellt,
jetzt ist es besser, excellent. So, der Sibaro, was sagt der Sibaro, kannst du für eine i3
Konfig mal eine Rhythmie schreiben wie man die einfügen muss? Punkt Konfig, i3 Konfig,
wieso? Es gibt 2-3 Orte wo man die hinlegen kann, was soll ich denn schreiben? Ach so,
die Status Bar, so wie ich die habe, ja dazu brauchst du ja noch das Programm was die Status
Bar macht, also i3 Status RS brauchst du noch dazu, dass das funktioniert. So, ich zeige
euch jetzt schon mal grob was euch heute erwartet, es wird Windows, AP, also eklicher geht es
kaum, passt mal auf, also das erste was natürlich ein guter Programmierer macht, als wenn er
ein Problem hat ist, er sucht auf Stack Overflow danach, das heißt das werden wir jetzt auch
machen. So, also wir suchen so was wie Change Volumixer AP Windows Stack Overflow. So, und
das was wir finden ist dieses Beispiel hier, weil das habe ich mir vorher schon mal angeguckt,
ich mache mal kurz mal, die Musik ist MonkaS, ich mache mal kurz den Dark Reader aus, ja
machen wir auch mal den Dark Reader aus, es ist Früh am Tag, da wird es mal Dark Reader,
also genau das wollen wir machen, Controlling Volumixer, also sprich das da, was wir hier
haben, auch übrigens, ich hoffe es sieht keiner meine Hacks, die ich im Hintergrund laufen
habe, ich meine irgendwie muss ich ja auch mal den Aimbot hier verstecken langsam, Wallhack,
Aimbot, das gibt es da sonst noch alles, Trackingbot, Tradebot, alles hier, Main Window, ja zumindest
also dieses Ding hier, das ist halt die Windows 7 Variante, Not Leaked, Chat ist drüber,
du denkst, dass es Not Leaked war, vielleicht war es ja auch Absicht, vielleicht war es
ja auch Absicht, ich sehe jetzt in der Vorschau, dass der Chat gleich weg ist und jetzt blende
ich es aus und ihr habt nichts gesehen, also ich schiebe es mal hier in die Mitte, also
das hier ist der Windows Mixer, den kennen wir ja alle, den kann man übrigens auch breiter
machen, es macht nur irgendwie keiner und es ist lustigerweise egal, wie sehr man ihn
verschiebt, immer unten rechts und immer wieder klein, also man kann ja auf die Idee
kommen können, dass Microsoft so clever ist und sich merkt, wie groß man das Mixer Fenster
gemacht hat, wir haben 69 Zuschauer, exellent, wie groß und wo man das Mixer Fenster haben
will, aber Microsoft hat sich gedacht, juckt uns nicht, ist uns vollkommen egal, du kannst
das Fenster so schieben wie du willst, aber danach wird es wieder resettet, also das ist
der Windows Mixer hier, das ist eine Frage, die einer gestellt hat vor sieben Jahren,
das ist also schon ein bisschen älter, es hat sich Windows API technisch, Sieg, macht
voll nervös, ja Audioeinstellungen sind generell Monarch S unter Windows, guck mal, Monarch
S hat auch Transparency, so und also das wollen wir einstellen, so, das Problem dabei ist,
dass Microsoft sich gedacht hat, es ist eine gute Idee, dafür keine moderne API anzubieten,
also mit modern eigentlich nicht was funktioniert, sondern irgendwas, was sich halbwegs normal
bedienen lässt, so und deswegen funktioniert das ganze folgendermaßen, das ganze nennt
sich Windows Core Audio API, so und wenn man da danach sucht, wird es schon mal ganz ekelig,
dann wird es schon mal ganz ekelig, übrigens eine der weiteren Sachen, die mit UWP nicht
funktioniert, so und da gibt es hier zig Milliarden Interfaces, da gibt es ja sowas
tolles wie iAudio Endpoint Format Control und was wir brauchen werden ist ein iSimple
iAudio Volume Interface, also was die sich dabei bei Microsoft wieder gedacht haben,
Ear Trumpet, das kann man machen, ja man kann fertige Sachen nehmen, das kenne ich übrigens
noch gar nicht, die Sache ist bloß die, wenn man fertige Sachen nimmt, lernt man nichts,
das ist übrigens Open Source Ear Trumpet, ich hab Mist erzählt, natürlich kenne ich
das, das ist Open Source, das kann man sich auf GitHub angucken wie es funktioniert, ja,
das ist im Prinzip der Windows Mixer nur in besser, aber wenn man was fertiges nimmt,
da lernt man nichts, wir wollen ja was lernen, wir sind ja Stonks IQ, so und das hier sind
so ganz tolle Interfaces und Sachen, wo sich Microsoft gedacht hat, genau so muss man das
machen, ja, so dass man zum Beispiel auch den IKS Jack Description 2 Interface, genau
das wollte ich auch schon immer öffnen, also ganz tolle, ganz tolle, ganz tolle, ganz
tolle API, die sich der Microsoft gedacht hat, dass das eine gute Idee ist und um euch
mal ein, Moment, ich hab es doch gerade, what the fuck, Windows, so und Microsoft hat sich
halt gedacht, ja, das ist zu einfach, wenn wir da einfach ein paar API Aufrufe anbieten
so wie Set Global Volume oder Set Application Volume by ID oder sowas, das ist zu einfach,
so, deswegen hat sich Microsoft gesagt, das macht man damit, das habe ich euch ja gerade
schon gezeigt und hier ist ein, alter was ist hier los, hier, was macht der Darkreader
für komische Dinger, der Darkreader soll mal hier nicht rum nerven und aufhören zu
Dark zu readern, wenn ich nicht will, oder habe ich Stack Overflow vielleicht auf Dark
stehen, falls das überhaupt geht, hat Stack Overflow einen Darkseam, vielleicht haben
wir auch irgendwie eine Hexer auf dem Recher, da müssen wir gleich mal gucken, ja, Twitchchat
hat mich gehackt, guck hier, ja, ich sehe es schon, Microsoft Photos, das ist eindeutig,
der Twitchchat, so und hier gibt es ein Beispielprogramm, das habe ich mir im Vorfeld schon angeguckt
und ich muss euch sagen, auf den ersten Blick, man checkt nichts, das hier sieht ja noch
relativ simpel aus, ne, so nach dem Motto, ok, er sucht nach Firefox, listet sich alle
Anwendungen auf, sucht dann die Anwendung raus, die Firefox heißt und sagt dann Muted
bzw. setzt das Volume auf 50%, das klingt logisch, aber ihr seht hier schon wie lang
das Programm ist, der logische Teil endet genau jetzt, das logisch endet genau jetzt,
so und jetzt kommt Microsoft Big Brain API zum Tragen und zwar hier, ja, wenn man sich
sowas schönes schon anguckt, tippt mir hier, man braucht nämlich den EMM Device Enumerator,
ja, dann, dann braucht man den Default Audio Endpoint natürlich mit diesem ganz klar,
dass man hier E-Render und E-Multimedia braucht, dann müssen wir irgendwelche Interface-IDs
uns raussuchen, nämlich den IEID iAudioSessionManager2, den müssen wir dann irgendwie uns eine Referenz
zu holen mit einem absolut selbsterklärenden API Aufruf, man müsste dann nämlich sagen,
wenn wir hier, das Default Audio Interface ist bei mir übrigens nicht Speaker, sondern
mein optischer Audio Ausgang, so und dann sagt man hier Activate, warum auch immer Activate,
was auch immer es dann heißt, ja, da übergeben wir dann die ID für das Interface des Audio
Session Manager 2s, dann müssen wir auch irgendwelche Obscuren, siehst du, ich bin schon wieder
kurz vorm abkratzen, wenn ich das sehe, ok, es wartet mal kurz, exellent, da sind wir
wieder, so, da muss man irgendwelche Obscuren-Parameter übergeben, Null, Null-Pointer und dann kriegt
man ein Object zurück, was man dann wiederum zu einem iAudioSessionManager2 casten kann,
alles klar so weit, so, das machen wir dann noch ein paar Mal und in jedem Fall kriegen
wir dann Sachen zum Steuern des Windows-Mixers raus und das müssen wir alles wieder aufräumen,
das ist gute alte Windows-Crap-RP, was wir hier haben, i3-Status-Rust, ja, richtig sehbar
auch, so, wunderbar, so machen wir das, genauso werden wir das machen und damit wir schon
anfangen können, copypasten wir uns mal, ach ja, übrigens, wer sich jetzt gefragt hat,
woher diese iAudioSessionManager2 Interfaces überhaupt kommen, es gibt nicht irgendwie
ein paar Sachen, die man einbinden kann, dass man die Sachen, dass man das verwenden kann
von Microsoft, ne, ne, die muss man selber definieren, glücklicherweise hat dieser Typ
hier in dem Beispiel schon ein paar Sachen definiert, ansonsten dürfte man sich nämlich
komplett durch die Windows-API-Dokumentation kämpfen, zum Beispiel hier importiert er
das iAudioSessionManager2 Interface, was natürlich ganz selbsterklärend diese interne ID hat
also, ich glaub, die kennt jeder, der schon mal Windows verwendet hat, der weiß genau
das 77AA99A01BD6484F8BC72C65C9A9B64, das iAudioSessionManager2 Interface ist, kann
jeder, oder, chat, Hand aufs Herz mal ehrlich, wer kann's nicht, die braucht man jeden Tag,
genau, ja, P-Invoke, da könnte man auch gucken, aber die Dinger sind wahrscheinlich, wir
gucken mal, ob's da gibt, die Dinger sind wahrscheinlich so obscure und sonst wie, dass
die wahrscheinlich gar nicht da draufstehen, Dark Reader, fuck mich dat ab, geh aus, so,
wisst ihr, die Dinger sind so abgedreht, die stehen noch nicht mal hier drinnen, Dark Reader
geht nervlich rum, Alter, irgendjemand hat gerade gefragt, was programmiert wird, ich
versuche was, ich versuche, ich weiß ja nicht, ob das funktioniert, ich versuche, über
die Windows API, Programme, die immer ihre Lautstärke ändern, wie z.B. Modern Warfare
beim Starten stellt sich immer wieder auf 100% zurück, oder mein Mikrofon, was permanent
von Skype und Teams umgestellt wird, dass ich im Hintergrund checke, ob gewisse Anwendungen
gestartet sind, und wenn gewisse Anwendungen gestartet sind, dann stellt es mein Audio-Settings
auf einen vorher definierten Stand ein, also sprich, es stellt Modern Warfare auf 13%
Lautstärke, und es stellt mein Mikrofon auf 71% Lautstärke, werden da Seitenelemente
neu geladen, ja, ich glaube, es werden Seitenelemente neu geladen, wenn Chrome den Tab inaktiv macht,
oder sonst was, was auch immer das Ding für Schmerzen hat, nur Konsole oder mit GUI, na,
erstmal Konsole, weil man ja schauen muss, wie es funktioniert, danach vielleicht mit
GUI, wobei ich sagen muss, ich wüsste nicht, wozu man da ein GUI braucht, man muss zwei
Parameter einstellen, Lautstärke vom Game und Lautstärke vom Mikrofon, das werde ich
erstmal Hardcoden, um zu gucken, wie es funktioniert, danach ist es wahrscheinlich sogar einfacher,
man macht eine Konfig-Datei mit zwei Zeilen, anstatt da irgendwie GUI drumherum zu bauen.
Es gibt eine Library für Audio-Sachen, ja, aber ich will erstmal gucken, wie man das
selbst macht, und danach verwenden wir vielleicht sogar die Library, weil es einfacher ist,
und nicht so fehleranfällig, aber ihr habt es jetzt gesehen, solche absoluten Big-Brain-Sachen
müssen wir machen.
Ich habe übrigens mein Chat-Log-Tool in weißer Voraussicht mal direkt gestartet, dass ich
nichts vergesse, dass ich nichts vergesse, jetzt muss ich es nur nochmal leer machen,
dass ich nichts übersehe.
Ja, habe ich schon gesehen.
Ja, hatten wir schon, genau, Sound-Changer, ja, volume-Changer, nicht Sound-Changer, volume-Changer.
So, also wir kopieren uns mal dieses, also so wie das jeder guter Programmierer macht,
kopieren wir uns erstmal das Beispiel von Stack Overflow, so fangen alle Programme an.
Ja, und dann kopiert man sich einfach aus ein paar weiteren Threads noch ein paar Sachen
dabei, und dann ist es fertig, easy.
Okay, was haben wir hier, Console-App 13, kann man die löschen oder recyceln oder wiederverwenden
für irgendwas?
What?
Ah, EGIT, ich weiß was das war, das war unser Versuch mit WinUI, mit WinUI, Preview 2 oder
so, ne ne, jetzt die Musik wieder leise.
So, also machen wir mal ein neues Projekt, eine.NET Core Console Application, die den
tollen Namen kriegt, Console-App 14, dass ich es auch ja wieder finde danach.
Äh, Patrick sagt, es gibt halt save, nur eine Person, die sich schafft, kann alle anderen
kopieren den Code weiter, ja, ist klar, alles schon skeet, alle copy-pasten nur schon skeet.
Kann man auch mit.NET Core einen Task-Manager machen, ja, geht sogar ziemlich gut, also
wenn du sowas hier machen willst, das geht ziemlich gut, ja, das geht ziemlich gut, sowas
hier mit.NET Core zu machen, man könnte sowas modernes machen mit WinUI, wenn es dann irgendwann
mal benutzbar ist, mit UWP nicht, so ohne weiteres, weil UWP hat keinen Zugriff auf
diese Information, ne gut, Cross-Platform nicht, nein, Cross-Platform nicht, Task-Manager
Cross-Platform ist schwierig, weil die eigentliche Sache, wie man Task-Information abruft, ist
halt sehr plattformspezifisch, also unter.NET, um es mal ganz kurz zu zeigen, wie man
das machen will, unter.NET ist es ziemlich einfach, sowas wie eine Task-Liste zu bekommen,
da gibt es hier nämlich schon was fertiges, nennt sich Process, ist eingebaut im Framework,
kann man nicht einfach sagen, Process, Moment, man konnte doch alle, get-processes, Alter,
man muss hier leckt, was ist hier los, what the fuck, das leckt ja huge, so und jetzt kann
man sich alle, die Namen aller laufenden Prozesse ausgeben lassen zum Beispiel, guckt hier,
das ist alles, was läuft, bei mir, das ist ganz praktisch, weil der Kram schon eingebaut
ist, das werden wir heute übrigens auch noch brauchen, so aber wir wollten uns ja das Testprogramm
mal copy-pasten, excellent, so waren wir das, so also, wo gehts los, oh, hab ich irgendwas
nicht mit, oh ich hab die Hälfte nicht mit copy-pastet, wartet mal kurz, hab ich irgendwas
nicht mit copy-pastet, müssen wir das ganze noch mal machen, so jetzt aber, what, warum
kopiert das die Hälfte nicht mit, ok, machen wirs mal von oben nach unten, ah, von oben
nach unten gehts, excellent, selbstverständlich, warum solls ja auch von oben nach unten und
nach oben nicht funktionieren, ist ja logisch, so, also, firefox, das können wir doch gleich
mal ausprobieren, wir haben dann firefox hier drauf, da gehen wir jetzt mal auf youtube
und machen irgendwas an, so, irgendwas, ist vollkommen egal was, machen hier mal die Musik
aus und da sollte jetzt firefox, wenn ich den Beispielcode richtig verstehe, sollte da
firefox muten und danach auf 50% setzen, das können wir ja gleich mal ausprobieren, so
firefox steht auf 30%, ok, schauen wir mal, hat gemutet, excellent, hat funktioniert,
hat er gesehen, wenn man jetzt hier auf firefox mixer guckt, ist er auch bei 50%, ungemuted,
jetzt er wieder unmuted, also sprich, die Beispielanwendung scheint zu funktionieren,
das ist auch schon mal was, weil es funktionieren nicht immer alle Beispielanwendungen, easykiller
fragt warum das so ein Krampf ist, stackoverflow zu copy-pastet, vielleicht wollen sie nicht,
dass man so viel copy-pastet, weiß nicht, wir sind fertig für heute, easy, funktioniert,
ich denke auch auf copy-pastet, so, wir werden jetzt ein bisschen aufräumen, weil wir fangen
jetzt erstmal nicht mit set volume oder sonst was an, sondern das erste, was wir machen
ist, einfach nur mal alle Anwendungen auflisten, die Audioausgabe gerade machen und das sind
aktuell welche, wo es keine Namen für gibt, außer irgendwie eine audio-sav-dll, was auch
immer, also sprich, der Code ist schon mal ein bisschen unglücklich, weil die Namen
der Anwendungen nicht bei allen Sachen drinstehen, bei firefox hat es aber funktioniert, wartet
mal, firefox geht glaube ich, probieren wir mal aus, firefox, machen wir da irgendwas
dran, ah guckt, firefox geht, das heißt, das Beispiel ist nicht komplett, wir kriegen
nicht die notwendigen Informationen raus, um feststellen zu können, welche Anwendung dahinter
steckt und ich gehe mal davon aus, das liegt daran, weil die windows apis für die Soundgeschichten
einfach schon genauso eklig sind seit windows 7 und sich seit windows 7 nichts mehr, ich
meine, guckt euch das an, das sieht absolut, das sieht aus wie hingekotzt, also das liegt
jetzt nicht an dem, der das Beispiel gemacht hat, sondern dass Microsoft wieder sich sowas
ekliges ausgedacht hat und ich vermute einfach mal, dass es ein paar neuere interface-Versionen
gibt, davon, das habe ich hier nämlich auch schon glaube drin gesehen, hier holt er sich
den Namen der Anwendung raus und das funktioniert für firefox, allerdings für chrome, wie wir
gesehen haben, funktioniert das nicht, sonst würde ja hier bei anwendung die audio machen,
wenn wir hier chrome drin stehen, das heißt, wir müssen jetzt erstmal gucken, ob es hier
nicht ein interface gibt, was zum beispiel noch die Prozess-ID oder sowas hat, weil Prozess-ID
ist gut, wenn ich die Prozess-ID von der jeweiligen Anwendung rauskriege, dann kann ich mir alle
möglichen Sachen holen, also sprich, welcher fahrt, welche Argumente, theoretisch sogar
welches Icon das Ding verwendet, aber dazu brauche ich erstmal die Prozess-ID und ich
glaube, ich habe hier schon was gesehen, in den Kommentaren vorhin, wo drinnen stand,
dass man ein anderes interface verwenden kann, nämlich, wo ist es denn, hier, guck genau,
we could also use the Prozess-ID instead of app name und natürlich mit dem absolut logisch
klingenden Interface I-Audio-Session-Control 2, aktuell verwenden wir noch I-Audio-Session-Control,
wenn wir die Prozess-ID haben wollen, müssen wir natürlich selbstverständlich I-Audio-Session-Control
2 verwenden, klar, also, probieren wir das mal aus und das funktioniert nicht, weil es
I-Audio-Session-Control 2 nicht gibt, das heißt, wir müssen uns jetzt irgendwo im Internet
die Definition von I-Audio-Session-Control 2 raussuchen, das sagt übrigens Microsoft,
wie das ganze aussieht, das ist ein Beispiel C++, was auch immer, das heißt, wir müssen
jetzt mal ein Beispiel raussuchen, wo irgendjemand den Kram schon mal definiert hat für uns,
was ist denn das, iOS-Developer, iOS-Developer und da gibt's, what the fuck, ok, wo gibt's
denn eine Definition für I-Audio-Session-Control 2, wisst ihr was, wir machen jetzt mal Big
Brain, wir suchen einfach auf, ah, guck mal hier, csharp-hot-examples.com, choose my name,
ich wüsste das jetzt auch nicht, nur weil ich wusste, was da drinsteht, ok, I-Audio-Session-Control
2 und leider ist es oft so, wenn man irgendwelche Windows-API programmieren will, dass das
wildes Gesuche und zusammengecopy-paste ist, ah, guck mal hier, audiomanager.js, jetzt
geht's, jetzt wird's Big Brain hier, wo ist die Definition, hier, bam, das brauchen wir,
I-Audio-Session-Control 2, genau das, so wir schmeißen jetzt mal ein paar Sachen raus,
also diese ganze Volume-Geschichte brauchen wir nicht, das hab ich ja gerade entfernt,
das brauchen wir auch, oder, geht das überhaupt noch, das können wir auch rausschmeißen,
das machen wir dann nachher wieder, wenn's daran geht, wirklich die Lautstärke zu setzen,
das Application-Volume kann auch raus, oh, wo hab ich, wo hab ich jetzt, wo hab ich jetzt
was zu viel gelöscht, ach hier, exellent, hier hab ich was zu viel gelöscht, ah, jetzt
funktioniert's, so, dann machen wir mal weiter mit unserem copy-paste-driven-programming-style,
wir kopieren uns den Grammi einfach mal rüber, und das ist jetzt I-Audio-Session-Control 2,
das erste ist not-implemented, ah, yes, exellent, natürlich, warum auch immer, und das nächste,
get-process-id, das ist das, was wir brauchen, set-ducking-preference, ich hab ehrlich gesagt
keinen Plastenschimmer, wofür der ganze Gramm ist, den ich hier sehe, aber process-id brauchen
wir, so, das heißt, anstatt dass wir jetzt hier I-Audio-Session-Control uns holen, holen
wir uns I-Audio-Session-Control 2, bam, und da gucken wir uns mal an, ah, nee, could not
convert, okay, dann, wir casten, wir casten das einfach mal, easy, das lässt sich bestimmt
casten, war-temp, man muss jetzt auch gleich mit guten Namen anfangen, S-I-Audio-Session-Control
2, übrigens, chat, falls es den Anschein erweckt, ich wüsste, was ich mache, ich hab
keinen Plastenschimmer, was ich mache, gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt schon mal crasht oder
nicht crasht, es crasht nicht, das ist schon mal ein gutes Zeichen, für das es prinzipiell
geht, was wir hier machen, so, was haben wir jetzt hier, get-process-id, geht nicht, ja,
gut, einfach get-process-id aufrufen, das kann ja so nicht funktionieren, wäre nur einfach
logisch, dass es funktioniert, okay, wir kriegen den Rückgabewert, kriegen wir als Referenz
und nicht etwa als Return-Code von dem Funktions-Aufruf, also ist wahrscheinlich der Return-Wert
von diesem Funktions-Aufruf irgendein Error-Code, den wir natürlich nicht checken werden, Control
2, nee, Quatsch, ID, so, ID, so, schauen wir mal, ob wir jetzt die Prozess-ID kriegen,
ah, das sieht doch schon besser aus, guck mal, hier kriegen wir eine Prozess-ID, 6052,
2052, was auch immer, exellent, genau, es funktioniert, mit der Prozess-ID kann man
jetzt schon was anfangen und ich zeige euch auch, was man mit einer Prozess-ID anfangen
kann, man kann jetzt nämlich zum Beispiel sagen, process, get-process-by-ID und da stopfen
wir die Prozess-ID rein und wenn wir Glück haben, läuft es jetzt ohne Fehler durch, okay,
es crasht nicht, das ist schon mal schön und jetzt können wir uns sowas ausgeben lassen
wie Prozess-Name und da würde ich jetzt erwarten taucht sowas wie Chrome drin auf, Vmware,
Chrome, OBS, Web-Application 11, damit kann man jetzt zum Beispiel schon was anfangen,
also der Name stimmt hier nicht, aber wir können jetzt anstatt den Name zu returnen einfach,
das können wir uns hier nämlich schenken, wir returnen jetzt einfach den Prozess-Name
und schon funktioniert es, so, so, das ist doch schon mal besser, jetzt kriegen wir hier
nämlich den Namen der Anwendung raus, so sollte das Ganze auch sein, damit kann man jetzt
schon ein bisschen was anfangen, noch schöner war Window-Name, das stimmt, ich vermute aber
mal, dass das hier unter der Haube wahrscheinlich sowas wie Window-Name ist, probieren wir mal,
Main-Window-Title, ja, nee, Name, was haben wir sonst noch so, Prozess-Name, Machine-Name,
okay, das ist der Name von meinem Desktop-Rechner oder, ah nee, da ist Punkt, alles klar, Windows-Logik,
wir bleiben bei Process-Name, ja, das werden wir wahrscheinlich auch machen, nee, werden
wir nicht machen, wir machen uns eine eigene Klasse für und schauen wir mal, ich hab noch
keine Ahnung, wie der Kram überhaupt funktioniert, nee, Prozess-Name ist schon ganz gut, weil
wenn ich dann das Spiel starte, vielleicht hat das gar kein Titel, ne, könntest du
auch direkt, ähm, Windig-Abonnier-Twitch-Pribe, excellent-Subscription, der Chat-IQ ist heute
eh schon so hoch wie lange nicht mehr, übrigens, falls ich Subs übersehe, flamet mich mal
ein bisschen, okay, also das funktioniert schon mal, das heißt, wir kriegen jetzt den Prozess-Name,
alles gut, dann räumen wir den Kram mal ein bisschen auf, ähm, also erstmal schmeißen
wir natürlich alle Kommentare raus, weil Code mit Kommentaren ist ja nur wirklich overrated,
wir wissen ja, dass sich guter Code selbst dokumentiert, da brauchen wir keine Kommentare,
so, ähm, dann, in die Kommentare lassen wir drin, das war bescheuert, die Kommentare
rauszuschweißen, ähm, Kommentare, lul, Windows-RP-Code liest sich am besten von allem ohne Kommentare,
das ist schon so kompliziert, da macht's, da machen es weniger Kommentare sogar noch
besser, so, also was machen wir denn jetzt, ähm, wir machen uns, ich hab ne Idee, ich
hab ne Idee, was wir jetzt machen, wir machen uns mal ne eigene Klasse, wo die ganzen Informationen
reinkommen, die wir brauchen, nachdem ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Plassen-Schimmer habe,
mit was ich hier überhaupt hantiere, hab ich auch nicht so ne große Ahnung, wie ich die
Klasse nennen soll, deswegen nenne ich die einfach Mixer-Entry oder sowas, ich weiß
nicht, was es wirklich ist, also sprich, hier so ein Eintrag davon, quasi so, und das Ding
hat nen, das Ding hat nen Name, vielleicht, vielleicht, das kann Null sein, das weiß
man nicht so genau, denn die Klasse CACW, das machen wir dann zum Schluss, so, dann hat
das Ding eine, äh, Process-ID, ok, und jetzt returnen wir keine Strings, sondern Mixer-Entries,
so, da kommen wir der Sache doch schon näher, so, und anstatt, dass wir jetzt hier so ne
komische Big-Brain-Yield-Return-Geschichte machen, adden wir einfach hier immer ein Mixer-Entry,
der bekommt nen Name, der bekommt nen Name, und zwar ist das Process dort Name, Process-Name
und da bekommt ne ID, und das ist, ähm, ID, so, damit kann man jetzt schon ein bisschen
mehr anfangen, achso, ich muss es noch zurückgeben, damit kann man jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr
anfangen, allerdings, äh, müssen wir das ein bisschen in Main ändern, so, und zwar
haben wir jetzt einmal hier den Name, und das ist hier unsere Spezialklasse, dort Name,
und ähm, ne ID, mach mal Leerzeichen, und das ist unsere, mein Visual Studio laggt,
wie sau, was ist denn da los, übrigens die Frage, warum kein Rider kam vorher, weil
ich unter Windows eigentlich fast immer Visual Studio verwende, aber wenn ich heute nur noch
Windows verwende, verwende ich eigentlich nur Rider, gibt ja auch keine anderen Alternativen,
so wirklich, ne, so, guck mal, funktioniert, wir machen jetzt nochmal hier so nen Trenn-Strich
dazwischen, das wir sehen, bei den unterschiedlichen Sachen, also, wir haben folgende Anwendung,
machen gerade Audio-Ausgabe, VMWare, mit der, mit der Process-ID, ähm, Web-Application-11,
mit der Process-ID, wer sich fragt, was Web-Application-11 ist, das ist BigBrain-Benahmung für unter
anderem das hier, also das Programm, was hier die Bilder und Sound-Overlays macht,
das ist Web-Application-11, ich bin ja bekannter für meine Anwendung, so zu benennen, dass
man sie sich gut merken kann, dementsprechend Web-Application-11, und hier haben wir zur
Abwechslung mal Console-App 14, haha, choose my name, doch, das wäre richtig C++ da eine,
ja, gut, so, damit können wir doch jetzt schon mal arbeiten, da haben wir doch jetzt schon,
wir haben den Name, und wir haben eine Process-ID, so, als nächstes, ähm, Name Eidl-ID 0, ja,
das ist irgendeine Windows-interne Geschichte, was auch immer uns Windows damit sagen möchte,
keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist das der Prozess-Scheduler oder sowas, keine Ahnung, ID 0 spricht irgendwie
für Display-Manager, naja, komm mal, Web-Application-11 und Console-App 14, da weiß man wenigstens
noch was es ist, ja, was ein iAudio-Session-Manager 2 ist, mit diesem komischen Zeug da, das weiß
keiner, außerdem, meine Sache ist auch nicht public und Microsoft released ihre Sachen
public und möchte, dass andere Leute sie verwenden können, das ist ja der große Unterschied,
mir ist es egal, ob andere Leute mein Kram verwenden können, aber Microsoft will, dass
andere Leute ihren Kram verwenden können, so, Mixer-Entry, Enumerate-Applications, das
ist doch schon mal schön, was richtig cool wäre, ähm, Not Impel 2, ich glaube nicht,
dass es ein Microsoft-Ding ist, hier, ich vermute mal, das ist was von demjenigen, von
dem wir das Copy-Pasted haben, und zwar möchte der ja, dass, ähm, quasi die, ich weiß nicht,
ob da irgendein Struct unten drunter ist, dass die Abstände, wo die einzelnen Speicher-Bereiche
beginnen, dass die an der richtigen Stelle sind, so, und wenn er die erste Funktion
nicht braucht, allerdings die nächste Funktion, quasi, irgendwie ein paar Bites später startet,
definiert er hier halt was, was den ersten Slot belegt, den er halt nicht braucht.
So, was ist eigentlich PreserveSig?
Indicates, dass, was, ageResult, das ist in irgendeiner Windows-Rückgabe Wertgedöns,
was takes place during COM-Interop-Calls should be suppressed, was, was, was macht das?
Indicates, also, dass das ageResult, oder Rückgabe Wert, die Signaturtransformation,
dass, während, die während dem COM-Interop auftreten, unterdrückt wird.
What?
Okay, just, just Windows-Things, ich hab, weiß nicht, wirklich keine Ahnung, was uns
das sagen soll.
Wir lassen es jetzt aber mal da drinnen, weil es im Beispiel drinnen ist, und es funktioniert.
Und ich könnte wetten, wenn wir das wegmachen, geht's nicht, ich mach das mal weg, mal gucken,
ob es dann kaputt geht.
Nee, geht immer noch, ach yes, das funktioniert immer noch.
Ich lass es, ich lass es einfach mal da.
So, was jetzt richtig cool wäre natürlich, wenn wir diese, wenn wir das hier irgendwie
schaffen, dass man hier letztendlich sagen kann, public void set volume, das wäre natürlich
richtig pro, wenn das funktioniert, weil da wäre das in der Handhabung ziemlich einfach
unterm Strich.
Set volume, gut, das Ganze kriegt einen, kriegt das denn?
Float, Floats sind immer sehr beliebt dafür, weil man das von 0 bis 1 machen kann, so für
Prozent.
Komm, scheiße, wir machen ein Int, ist doch wurscht, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es weitergeht.
Das wäre natürlich cool, wenn man das hier macht, also wenn wir das schaffen, das hier
irgendwie zu implementieren, weil dann könnte ich an der Stelle nämlich einfach sagen,
machen wir mal so ein Beispiel, also sprich, wenn der, wenn der Name, dann sagen wir was,
keine Ahnung, Chrome enthält, ach hier, wenn der Name Chrome enthält, dann sagen wir
set volume auf, keine Ahnung, 15%, so das wäre natürlich pro, wenn das funktionieren
würde.
Ich meine, es funktioniert jetzt nicht, weil wir haben nichts implementiert hier, aber
von der Idee her wäre das natürlich nice, wenn man das so hinkriegen würde.
So, ähm, die große Preisfrage ist jetzt natürlich nur, wie setzt man die Lautstärke
von der Anwendung, das probieren wir mal aus, das gucken wir uns hier ab, das steht doch
hier irgendwo drinnen, dark reader, wartet mal kurz, ich muss das disablen, da geht mir
gerade voll auf den Kick, set dark reader, so, ähm, wo hatten wir es denn, set application
volume, name float level, name brauchen wir nicht, name haben wir hier, äh, name haben
wir hier selbst drinnen, set application volume, get volume object, ok, i simple audio volume,
ah, siehst du, sogar Microsoft lacht uns aus, wie einfach das ist, also wenn i simple
audio volume uns nicht sagen soll, dass wir absolute Kacknoobs sind, i simple audio volume,
get volume object, was ist denn hier los schon wieder, what the fuck, Moment, das ist doch
genau das gleiche wie unten, get volume object, das ist genau das gleiche wie hier, i simple
audio volume, wo kriegt er das her, der casted i audio session control 2 zu i simple audio
volume, das probieren wir jetzt aus, vielleicht ist es viel einfacher als ich denke, die Musik
ist mir zu anstrengend, ich brauche, ich brauche irgendwas anderes, relaxing Nintendo music,
ah, perfekt, ah, yes, excellent, das ist doch viel entspannender, so, also was mal, i audio
session, i audio session control, casted dazu i simple audio volume, ok, wir probieren jetzt
einfach mal aus, ob das funktioniert, also, control s i simple audio volume, scheint zu
funktionieren, was du mit den 55.000 Kanalpunkten anfangen sollst, ja, ausgeben, ich weiß gar
nicht, kann man da Belohnungen verwalten, ich gucke mal, ob es da noch mehrere Sachen
gibt, die man da einstellen kann, Belohnungen verwalten, ok, ich gucke mal, was es da so
für Möglichkeiten gibt, was man damit machen kann, Nachricht hervorheben, zufälliges
Abo-Emote entsperren, Nachrichten nur Abo-Modus senden, ich habe nie nur Sub-Only-Mode an,
individuelle Belohnungen erstellen, aha, hier gibt es noch jede Menge andere Sachen, welchen
Held soll ich spielen, das bringt es jetzt hier nicht wirklich, du darfst einen Charakter
oder Gegenstand im Spiel benennen, ja, das bringt es auch nicht wirklich, wir können
sagen, du darfst dir den nächsten Klassennamen aussuchen, ich spiele 5 Minuten lang mit
dem Controller rückwärts, what the fuck, nein, das passt bei mir alles gerade nicht,
was wird gebastelt, ich versuche mich gerade ein bisschen durch die Windows Audio-RP zu
kämpfen, sodass ich hinbekomme, dass ich automatisch bestimmte Anwendungen immer hardcoded
auf einen gewissen Audiowert setzen kann, z.B. wenn man Modern Warfare startet, dann setzt
sich das immer auf 100% Lautstärke, das soll auf 13% Lautstärke, mein Mikrofon soll auf
71% Lautstärke, hey Max, für wann planst du den Flutter Dart Stream, habe ich noch keine
genaue Idee, hier ist ein Vorschlag für Stream-Belohnungen, Punktebelohnungen für IRL-Streamer, lass mich
einen Schluck Wasser trinken, was eine bescheuerte Belohnung, ich trinke was ich will, ich glaube,
es geht los, lass mich einen Schluck Wasser trinken, was gibt es noch, ich setze mich
gerade hin, lass mich dabben, nein, außerdem sieht mich keiner, wenn ich dabbe, lass mich
sit-ups machen, oh ja, das hättet ihr gerne, 2500, die Belohnung ist geil, für 2500 wirst
du timeoutet, soll ich die Belohnung hinzufügen, ich weiß nicht wo das eine Belohnung sein
soll, aber gut, eine Umfrage hinzufügen, lass einen anderen Nutzer für 5 Minuten lang
sperren, WTF, nee, schlage vor, wen wir am Ende des Streams raiden, das ist ganz gut,
naja, gut, weiter, weiter im Text, ich muss wieder ein paar ordentliche Belohnungen, für
70k gibt es dann C++, nee, ich weiß, das haben manche Leute ja fast schon, also wo sind
wir stehen geblieben, also wir haben das jetzt als iSimpleAudioVolume gecastet, das brauchen
auch bessere, so und damit kann ich jetzt set volume, ok, was hat das für bescheuerte
Parameter, was, Event-Kontext, für 10k Facecam, der Chat, ja, nee, nee, nee, sowas gibts
nicht, da meint der Chat noch, er könnte hier komplett über die Schränke schlagen,
man darf dem Chat nicht zu viel frei halten lassen, sonst drehen sie durch, so, also
weiter im Text, wir kriegen jetzt hier ein iSimpleAudioVolume, was auch immer uns das
genau sagen soll, ich habe eine Idee, wisst ihr was wir machen, wir sagen jetzt einfach,
mal gucken ob das funktioniert, wir sagen jetzt einfach, wir machen einen Konstruktor,
der nämlich ein iSimpleAudioVolume bekommt und dann merken wir uns den und dann können
wir das relativ einfach ändern, so, internal, so set volume, ok, dann müssen wir den Konstruktor
noch füttern damit und zwar mit ctls iSimpleAudioVolume, ok, mal gucken ob es funktioniert, exzellent
scheint zu funktionieren und jetzt setzen wir mal das Audio, mal schauen ob das einfach
funktioniert, da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt, volume, set, volume, ok, also, wir setzen
jetzt mal das volume von chrome, da steht aktuell auf 25% und wir setzen jetzt das volume
auf 50%, what the fuck, was, was muss ich da als Parameter angehen, das muss ich abgucken,
what, empty, gut, ok, wenn der Beispieltexter sagt, dann machen wir das so, exzellent, ach
ne, das geht ja nicht, so, ob das jetzt funktioniert, also, der chrome sollte, der chrome sollte
sich gleich umschalten hier, ne, also hier ist der chrome jetzt bei 25% und ich setze
ihn jetzt auf 50%, die Frage ist, das muss ich auch noch herausstellen, was ist mit 50%
gemeint, ist es 50% vom maximal möglichen volume oder ist es 50% vom aktuell eingestellten
master volume, chrome gleich chromium, ja, so, gucken ob es funktioniert, oh, monk, monke
es, geht nicht, findet er den chromeprozess, ja, muss er, den muss er finden, den muss
er finden, weil er ist ja hier reingegangen und ist hier gecrashed, das heißt, das hier
hat funktioniert, klar, schick her, schick, irgendwie github, link, sonst was, ja, schick
mal her, stimmt, choose my name, ja klar, ist ja logisch, das muss weg, ich release das
ganze Jahr, ich release das ganze Jahr, ja klar, das muss weg, hey, es hat funktioniert,
guck mal, es ist 50%, es hat funktioniert, auf was stand chrome vorher, 30, ne, es hat
funktioniert, 25, auf 25 stand es, ok, machen wir mal null, dann sollte chrome jetzt sich
muten, hey, das funktioniert, ich bin begeistert, so, und jetzt, und jetzt machen wir mal 100%,
aber 100% dürfte ja dann jetzt von dieser logik, 100% würde in diesem Fall 30% bedeuten,
ok, mein volume ist, also mein master volume ist auf 30%, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt 100%
mache, sollte mein chrome auf 30% gehen, ja, ja, hört sich auch schon so an, sehr gut,
wir machen es vielleicht nicht mit chrome, sondern wir machen es mit dem firefox, dass
ich an meinem hintergrundmusik nichts rumstellen muss, machen wir, machen wir irgendwas, irgendwas,
oh ja, genau, was auch immer, hauptsache, ich brauche ja nichts abspielen, sondern ich
will ja einfach sehen, ob sich im mixer was ändert, so, um zu gucken, was ist denn das
aktuelle volume von firefox, 15, ok, 15, lassen uns das mal ausgeben, das heißt, wir machen
das jetzt nicht für chrome, sondern wir machen das für firefox, und jetzt, anstatt das volume
zu setzen, geben wir das volume mal aus, get, get master volume, war, out, vol, wat, war,
nee, umgedreht, out, war, so rum, so, mal gucken, was das volume ist, also von der logik
her müsste mein volume beim firefox jetzt 50 sein, ne, also 30% master volume, und die
hälfte von 30%, hier 15, müssten dann heißen, es ist gerade 50% vom maximal möglichen volume,
so, also da müsste jetzt eigentlich 50 rauskommen, ja, kommt auch, ok, es kommt nicht 50 raus,
es kommt 49, äh, 999997 raus, das geht aber als 50 durch, das ist ok, das ist ja quasi
50, der rest ist floating point, geschiss, so, die frage, die sich mir stellt, und die
ganze sache jetzt natürlich noch viel komplizierter macht, als ich das eigentlich gedacht habe,
ist folgende, wenn ich jetzt sagen möchte, ich glaube das ist echt kompliziert, was
ich vorher komplizierter als gedacht habe, also die sache ist ja die, ich möchte jetzt
sagen können, ok, mein chrome soll auf 25%, allerdings sind die 25% hier auf die Gesamtlautstärke
bezogen, und hier ist es dynamisch abhängig zur aktuell eingestellten master volume lautstärke,
also sprich ich muss das jetzt noch umrechnen von, in dem fall firefox, ich muss das jetzt
noch umrechnen, also sprich 15% im windows mixer entsprechen 50% in meiner anwendung,
das heißt ich muss irgendwie noch rausbekommen, auf wieviel mein master volume steht, kann
man mir so weit folgen, oder stimmt das überhaupt was ich erzähle, ich muss übelst husten,
was ist denn heute los, also was ich sagen will ist, ich kann hier über die windows api
es nur relativ einstellen zur master volume, allerdings im windows mixer, nachdem jetzt
meine settings sind, ist es von 100%, das heißt ich muss es umrechnen, was ist 25%
oder was sind 15% im windows mixer für dynamisches volume, gerade, exzellent, das heißt um das
machen zu können, müsste ich erstmal rausbekommen, wie laut ist mein lautsprecher eingestellt,
dass ich dann sagen kann, ok mein ziel, also ich will sagen, meine ziellautstärke für
firefox sind 15% von der gesamtlautstärke, 15% von der gesamtlautstärke kann ich hier
nicht einstellen, was ich einstellen kann sind 50% von dem 30% master volume, was dann
15% gesamtlautstärke sind, das kann ich machen, das heißt ich muss das master volume noch
rauskriegen und das dann irgendwie umrechnen, aber erstmal muss ich gucken, wie man das
master volume rauskriegt, wie bekommt man das master volume raus, muss man bestimmt,
ah exzellent, kann man bestimmt hier machen, guck mal, hier gibt es speakers, gibt es hier,
speakers, kann man auch bestimmt sagen, speakers, speakers, activate, nee ok, mehr kann man
nicht sagen, activate, also mein ziel ist jetzt, ich muss rausbekommen, wie laut meine
lautsprecher eingestellt sind, in dem fall hat mein audio ausgang, audio endpoint, ok
fahren wir mal google, audio, windows core audio, audio volume, speaker, finding current
volume level of speaker output, exzellent, aha da haben wir wieder mal so eine big brain,
das ist jetzt c++, hör mal auf, gehst du fort, also wer übrigens denkt normales c++
ist schon hässlich, hat noch kein windows api c++ gesehen, da wird es dann nämlich
richtig abartig, guckt euch das mal an, das ist wirklich schon körperverletzung hier,
wenn man sich das anguckt, das ist auch toll, ein void pointer pointer referenz, ach du
scheiße, was ist denn das, ok eine referenz zu audio endpoint volume, audio endpoint volume
brauchen wir, also das ist eine referenz zu audio endpoint volume und die wird gecasted
zu einem void pointer, der auf einen pointer pointet, exzellent und dann das ganze gemischt
mit so tollen bezeichnungen wie clsctx all, microsoft please alter, i audio endpoint volume,
das klingt doch gut oder, das klingt doch was nach dem was ich haben will, i audio endpoint
volume interface, volume controls on audio stream or from audio endpoint device, ok speaker,
speaker sind ein audio endpoint device, das heißt was ich jetzt brauche ist die definition
von i audio endpoint volume, das ist das schmerz den kram zu programmieren, ok, wir copy pasten
uns den kram echt irgendwie zusammen, wo ist das interface, ich brauch ne interface, ok
project, archived ist mir doch egal ob das archived ist oder nicht, aha wo ist das interface,
exzellent interface, copy paste beste, du hattest die copy und paste sogar angekündigt, naja
das war doch klar, ok, die brauchen wir eh nicht diese ganzen betonen hier, die schmeißen
wir raus, blickt da jemand aus dem chat durch, ich denke nicht, ich blick hier auch nicht
durch, ich hab absolut keine ahnung was ich da mache, aber es funktioniert, das ist ja
das erstaunliche dabei, so also jetzt haben wir hier ein i audio endpoint volume, sag
mal woher wissen die leute eigentlich was das ding für ne id haben muss, wie kommt
man da drauf, also irgendwo muss das doch stehen, ups ich such jetzt mal danach vielleicht
findet man dann die offizielle microsoft doko irgendwo, oh warte mal irgendeine wollte mir
noch vorn seinen volume helper schicken oder, ne den gab es doch nicht, also ich finde diese
sache nur ein beispiel, wo steht denn bei microsoft das man diese id braucht, ich mein irgendwo
muss man es doch her wissen, gibt es kein fertiges nougat package, doch bestimmt, will
aber wissen wie es funktioniert, das kann doch nicht sein, dass sich das leute einfach
über jahre hinweg irgendwo zusammengesucht haben und niemand weiß wo es offiziell steht,
das ist so typische microsoft crap geschichte wieder, ne es gibt es nicht, was am volume
mixer gemacht wird, wir stellen bestimmte anwendungen hardcoded auf einen gewissen audio volume
wert ein, weil sich zum beispiel wenn sich modern warfare startet stellt sich das immer
auf 100% und ich will es auf 13% haben und mein mikrofon wird auch von teams und skype
immer umgestellt, das soll auf 71%, sind halt capi sind sie sharpie, aber wo ist denn für
die capi, die das hier, das man das hier braucht, wo steht das denn, ich hab da jetzt nichts
gewonnen bei microsoft, also machen wir weiter, wir haben jetzt ein audio endpoint volume,
wir machen jetzt mal was ganz gewagtes, wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal speaker und nehmen
die einzige methode von speaker, nämlich activate und versuchen quasi anhand dieses
beispiels hier da ein audio endpoint volume raus zu bekommen, im c++ verwendet man doch
header files, ja das ist ja schön und gut, aber da muss es wenigstens irgendwelche header
files geben wo das drin steht, ich hab gesucht nach dieser zahl, microsoft.com und hab nix
gefunden, irgendwo muss es doch stehen, wahrscheinlich in irgendwelchen sdk's die es zum unterladen
gibt und es steht da seit 15 jahren drinne, bloß es hat noch keiner indiziert online
oder so, ok wie funktioniert der kram denn hier jetzt, also activate ref iid iaudio session
manager 2, ok wir machen jetzt genau das gleiche nur für iaudio endpoint volume, so iii ach
du große, meine güte, ok, eeid, keck, triple u, ok ref, eed, audio endpoint volume, na audio
endpoint, ja doch, eed, e audio endpoint volume, das ist anstrengend.
ok null, ich mach jetzt einfach genau das gleiche wie oben, ich mach exakt das gleiche
wie oben, ohne dass ich wüsste was die parameter alle machen, so out, o, ja ne, o nicht, b,
genau so, so brauchen wir das, perfekt, so und b, casten wir jetzt zu 1, ok, ee, vol,
ne, vol hammer glaube ich schon, volume gleich, b, mal gucken ob es crasht, es crasht nicht,
das ist schonmal gutes zeichen das es nicht crasht, ok volume, ee wenn das jetzt funktioniert
dann weiß ich mir echt den arsch, na, get master volume level haben wir und get master
volume level skala, ok wir schauen mal in der microsoft dokumentation was der unterschied
ist, ne, ich würd das gerne verschieben darf ich aber nicht, wenn die metoden namen zu
lang für die webseite sind ne, also hier, get channel volume level, ne master volume
level brauchen wir, indecibel und dann haben wir noch was anderes zu bieten skala, master
volume level im prozent quasi, alles klar, deswegen sind wir bescheid oder, also, ee,
so wollen wir hier sowas haben wie, get master volume level skala, was ist ich level, also
von der idee her sollte da jetzt 30 rauskommen, von der idee her sollte da jetzt 30 rauskommen,
schauen wir mal, also es sollte 30 rauskommen weil, mein master volume auf 30 prozent steht
ee 30 guck mal hier, moment, das funktioniert ja tatsächlich, ich hätte nie im leben gedacht
dass der scheiß so funktioniert, ich hab keine ahnung warum es funktioniert leute also das
dürft ihr mich nicht fragen aber es funktioniert, excellent chat, irgendwie hab ich das gefühl
ich brauch ne pause, ich kann mir den kram nicht mehr länger angucken, das ist ja so
massiv eklig, oh mal kurz, wer hat sich den kack ausgedacht, meine güde, und dabei sind
wir erstmal ne halbe stunde bei oder so ne, ok ich hab nix gesagt wir sind jetzt an der
stunde dabei, das ist echt anstrengend, ja wir gucken uns jetzt 3 min lego harvest machine
an und dann gehts weiter, excellent, die musik ist kokona, what the fuck, wtr fleude was
ist denn jetzt los, alter, die lösung hat uns gehostet, huge, dankeschön, boah geil,
1006er zuschauer, excellent ja, huge host, poggers, massive poggers, und jetzt gerade
wollte ich pause gemacht, oder gerade wollte ich nix machen, ich weiß gar nicht was ich
sagen soll ja, dankeschön für den host, massive, huge, big brain host, alter, ich
hab auch nix, das sind ein paar leute ja, etf, das ja cool, ja vielleicht kennt mich
da ein oder andere noch, ich hab früher auch mal auf youtube videos zu call of duty und
battlefield gemacht, allerdings in letzter zeit dann doch eher ein bisschen weniger,
Um nicht zu sagen, um nicht zu sagen gar nicht.
Wo ist der Friseur?
Der spielt komische Handyspiele.
Der Friseur spielt komische Handyspiele und...
...Asia grinding MMOs.
Ja, schön, dass ihr alle am Start seid. Nice.
Also mal ganz kurz zur Erklärung, was wir eigentlich machen für den einen oder anderen, den es vielleicht doch interessiert.
Ich versuch grad was zu programmieren und zwar...
Ihr kennt's ja alle, ne?
Ne, ihr kennt's nicht. Ihr spielt ja auf der PS4 zum größten Teil, oder?
Also es ist so...
Wenn man auf dem PC Modern Warfare startet...
...dann stellt sich die Lautstärke in Windows immer auf 100% von dem Spiel.
So, und das geht mir so extrem auf den Keks, dass ich gerade am überlegen bin, ob man nicht was programmieren kann.
Hiermit.
Ähm, was automatisch beim Starten von Modern Warfare die Lautstärke auf einen vorher definierten Wert stellt.
Und ich hab mir das relativ einfach vorgestellt.
Allerdings, nur mal so, ich geh mal davon aus, den meisten wird's nicht sagen.
Es sei euch aber gesagt, mir sagt es auch relativ wenig, weil ich einfach copy-paste.
Weil ich keine Ahnung hab, wie man Windows-Audio-Arpies verwendet.
Sieht dann so aus, wenn man versucht, Anwendungen unter Windows auf ein spezielles Volume zu setzen.
Und das meiste hab ich mir ehrlich gesagt zusammen copy-pastet.
Weil es wirklich extrem eklig unter Windows ist, sowas zu machen.
Ja, aber ich bin begeistert, dass echt so viele Leute am Start sind. Cool.
Ja, wir machen aber ganz normal weiter, ne?
Die Sache war bloß gerade die, diese Windows-AP-Geschichten, bzw. das Zeug hier unter Windows zu programmieren, ist so dermaßen eklig...
...dass ich gerade eigentlich ein bisschen Pause machen wollte.
Und das heißt, ihr kommt genau rechtzeitig, Leute.
Oder auch nicht, je nachdem, wie man's sieht.
Geht das nicht easy mit VoiceMeter?
Na ja, mit VoiceMeter kannst du viele Sachen machen, aber ich glaube, du kannst den VoiceMeter nicht...
...hardcoded sagen, diese Anwendung bekommt diese Lautstärke.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht.
Um euch mal zu zeigen, was ich meine, ist Folgendes.
Also sprich, wenn man sich jetzt einloggt...
...weil ich glaube, die meisten von euch spielen PS4, oder? Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Der behält die Einstellung. Nee, das Problem am Modern Warfare auf Windows ist, ich zeig's euch mal.
Also, wenn ihr Modern Warfare unter Windows startet, dann passiert Folgendes.
Ah, okay, ein paar spielen PC.
Also, wenn das Spiel dann irgendwann mal startet, weil das ist ja bekannt dafür, dass gerade Modern Warfare ein...
...absolut bug-freies und hochoptimiertes Spiel ist.
So, und wenn man jetzt hier rausgeht und in den Windows-Volume-Mixer guckt, wird man feststellen...
...das Spiel stellt sich immer auf 100%, immer.
Man kann da nichts dagegen machen, es stellt sich immer auf 100%.
So, und was ich jetzt gerade probiere, ist einzustellen, dass sich Modern Warfare von selbst runterstellt auf so ungefähr 13%.
Und selbst wenn ich das hier mache, und die meisten Anwendungen, da funktioniert das.
Bei allen anderen, oder sagen wir mal, eigentlich alle Anwendungen, außer Modern Warfare.
Wenn ich die einmal einstelle, und dann beende, und dann beende, und sie wieder starte, dann haben die sich das gemerkt.
Allerdings nicht Modern Warfare, wie ihr gleich sehen werdet. Wenn ich Modern Warfare nochmal starte, dann ist es wieder auf 100%.
Und das ist totaler Müll, und das versuche ich gerade zu fixen.
Wenn Infinity Ward da schon keinen Bock drauf hat, das zu fixen, dann mache ich das selbst.
Modern Problems require modern solutions. Ja, was willst du machen?
Guck, hier, steht wieder auf 100%. Jede andere Anwendung, guckt euch Firefox an.
Firefox, 15%, ich mache Firefox aus, ich mache Firefox an.
Stell es, keine Ahnung, ich mache auf YouTube irgendwas, irgendwas machen wir auf YouTube an.
Das Audio abspielt, es ist vollkommen egal was.
Guck mal, den Mixer rein, zack, Firefox, 15%.
Jede Anwendung, egal wie klein, wie schlecht, egal, egal, egal, egal, egal, egal.
Jede Anwendung, egal wie klein, wie schlecht, wie sonst was.
Stell es sich wieder richtig ein, bzw. Windows kann sie richtig einstellen.
Nicht so Modern Warfare. Ich vermute, ich habe nichts dazu gefunden, warum das so ist.
Ich vermute, dass es eben eine Anti-Cheat-Maßnahme ist.
Dass sich quasi die Anwendung jedes Mal minimal ändert, dass Windows sie nicht mehr erkennt und nicht richtig einstellen kann.
Aber es ist nur bei Modern Warfare so.
Ich bin ein Oldschooler, das könnte man so sagen, überlegt euch mal, ich bin jetzt 35 mittlerweile.
Bekommst du einen Wack-Bun?
Ich habe mir das Game nicht mal gekauft, im Prinzip bunnen die sich selbst dadurch.
Und das machen wir hier gerade. Mit Firefox funktioniert das Ganze auch schon.
Also sprich, ich kann Firefox einstellen. Das heißt, ich kann theoretisch auch Modern Warfare einstellen.
Gibt es eigentlich in Zwischenzeiten einen Baby-Keks?
Ich mag keine Kinder und ich mag... Ich dachte, ich mag keine Kinder.
Ich mag keine Kinder und ich mag keine Kinder.
Und ich mag... Ich dachte ja früher immer nur, ich mag keine Kinder.
Aber ich bin mittlerweile, und dafür habe ich ein paar Jahre gebraucht, bis ich das kapiert habe.
Ich bin mittlerweile zu dem Schluss gekommen. Ich mag keine Menschen.
Das sind nicht nur Kinder, die ich nicht mag. Ich mag keine... Außer den Chat natürlich.
Den Chat, der Chat ist... Den Chat mag ich.
Außer den Twitch-Chat. Der Twitch-Chat, ja der ist okay. Der Twitch-Chat ist... Der Twitch-Chat geht.
Der Twitch-Chat ist hier.
Moment, wo ist das passende E-Mode? Hier.
Genau sehbar, das meine ich. White Paper Blanket.
Das brauche ich übrigens. Übrigens mal als Beispiel.
Es sind jetzt ja relativ viele Leute gerade dazu gekommen.
Was ich so normalerweise in dem Stream mache. Vielleicht interessiert sich der eine oder andere ein bisschen für Technik-Sachen.
Ich mache gerade mal ein bisschen Werbung für mich, weil wenn ich jetzt mal dann...
So die letzten Videos, die wir... Oder die letzten Themen, die wir so gestreamt haben.
Also wir machen nicht immer Programmier-Streams. Wir machen aber zum größten Teil mache ich hier auf Twitch Technik-Grams.
Wogegen ich auf YouTube...
Oh, der eine oder andere kennt es ja vielleicht auf YouTube auch noch.
Auf YouTube habe ich ja hauptsächlich Gaming, Laberstell, sonst was gemacht.
Und auf Twitch mache ich was komplett anderes. Ich mache hauptsächlich Technik-Geschichten.
Also entweder programmieren wir was, wir gucken uns neue Linux-Geschichten an.
Wir haben uns zum Beispiel zusammen angeguckt, das Sony-Event.
Vor zwei Tagen.
Chat, was sagt ihr zum Sony-Event? Nachdem jetzt ja auch hier einige Playstation 4-Spiele am Start sind.
Was haltet ihr von der neuen Playstation 4?
Also meine persönliche Meinung dazu ist, erstens, sie sieht aus wie eine Fritz-Box.
Eine Fritz-Box mit weißen Seiten.
Aber der Stream, der Sony-Stream war so ein bisschen... War so.
Zum größten Teil war der Sony-Stream Resident-Sleeper extrem.
Dann ein paar Sachen wie beispielsweise Sackboy Adventures fand ich cool.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen war der Stream eher so.
Ja, also das war also... Ich weiß nicht, also ich denke mal da kommt noch ein bisschen was.
Ja, so Sachen treiben wir hier. Ab und zu gucken wir uns auch mal verschiedene Software an.
Vereinzelt kaufen wir auch mal Technik-Sachen im Stream ein.
Jeden Sonntagmorgen bin ich auch am Start. So zwei, drei Stunden zum Aufwachen.
Wo wir alles Mögliche uns angucken.
Ihr könnt ja mal durchgucken, ob das etwas ist, was euch gefällt.
Ist auf jeden Fall schön, dass so viele Leute jetzt mal vorbeigeguckt haben.
Ich bin mir auch im Klaren drüber, dass die Themen jetzt nicht unbedingt jeden ansprechen.
Aber ich freue mich über jeden, der da bleibt, der vielleicht ab und zu mal reinguckt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall...
Sehr nice.
Und eine Sache, die wir auch hier im Stream programmiert haben, die tatsächlich ganz cool ist, was ihr vielleicht auch schon gesehen habt.
Also nur mal für den Fall der Fälle, dass auch wenn man nicht so sehr dazu Bezug hat, dass da mal ein paar ganz coole Sachen bei rauskommen können.
Diese ganzen Overlay-Geschichten hier und der Sound.
Das haben wir auch im Stream selbst programmiert.
Wir haben uns hier im Stream so ein, ja quasi so ein Stream Deck Light gebastelt.
Was man im Browser bedienen kann, auch am zweiten Rechner im Browser, über ein Tablet im Browser.
Und das kann Overlay-Bildchen anzeigen oder Overlay-Sounds abspielen.
Und das ist was, wo ich glaube, dass das relativ viele Streamer gebrauchen können.
Unter anderem haben wir natürlich auch das beste Emote schlechthin.
Und für den aktuellen Zeitpunkt angemessen natürlich auch den hier.
So Sachen machen wir hier im Stream.
So, ich glaube, jetzt habe ich mich lang genug ausgeruht, jetzt können wir weitermachen.
Danny braucht so eins, ich dachte, Danny hat einen Stream Deck.
Das Tolle übrigens ist, wie ihr hier seht, diese Bildchen, ich sehe sie erstens selbst,
man kann sie eins verschieben, also man kann sich überlegen, wo man es anordnen will,
man kann es größer Kleider machen und es kann GIFs, ganz wichtig, es kann GIFs.
Und das Beste ist, es ist ein Overlay, was absolut nichts beeinflusst, also sprich, doch PNG kann es auch, PNG kann es auch, ja PNG kann es auch.
Man kann durchklicken, wie ihr seht.
Man kann durchklicken und es beeinflusst die Maus nicht, also man kann das auch in Spielen als Overlay verwenden.
Genau, der Chat, der Chat hat das natürlich programmiert, was sonst.
Und das Beste ist eigentlich, dass man es auf dem Tablet verwenden kann.
Und es steuern, weil ich brauche den Browser hier nicht, um es zu steuern.
IPS. Ja, und das allerbeste Feature von diesem, von meinem Memeboard ist, das allerbeste Feature ist,
dass wir eine japanische Text-to-Speech-Engine haben, die kann man eigentlich auch auf dem Tablet verwenden,
aber das allerbeste Feature von diesem, von meinem Memeboard ist, das allerbeste Feature ist, dass wir eine japanische Text-to-Speech-Engine haben, die zum Beispiel sowas hier sagen kann.
Also die wichtigsten Sachen oder auch ganz, ganz wichtig gerade für die ganzen Call of Duty Fans.
Call of Duty Fans.
Und um nicht zu vergessen, der legendäre, wo hab ich's, wo ist es, ja, falls ihr noch
einer kennt. Das ist glaube ich irgendein High Rise Modern Warfare 2 Sniper Clip.
MonkaS. Genau, Mummy, Camera. Ja. Genau, den Brauma.
Excellent. Ist das auf Github? Ja, eine uralt Version ist auf Github. Allerdings ist das
Problem, dass ich schon ewig nicht mal gepusht habe. Hier, da, ups, da war's. Dass ich schon
ewig nicht mal gepusht, vor allem die beste Commit Message überhaupt, dass ich schon ewig
nicht mal gepusht habe und die Version, die da drauf ist, nichts mit der Version zu tun
hat, die ich hier selbst habe. Also keine Voice, kein sonst was, kein GIF Support und
nix. Ich müsste die aktuelle Version mal wieder pushen, aber die ist so eklig programmiert,
die will ich eigentlich keinem zumuten. Pains Champ. Was, es gibt drei Forks? Ernsthaft?
Es gibt tatsächlich drei Forks, warum gibt's drei Forks? Dreckiger dann, auskenn, Fuchs,
okay. Gut zu wissen, es gibt drei Forks, warum auch immer. Wann kommt das nächste Gartenvideo?
Es gab schon ein paar Gartenvideos, allerdings hat sich der YouTube-Algorithmus immer gedacht,
Gartenvideos haben wir einmal promoted, danach juckt es keinen mehr. DevOps unter zwei Jahren
keine Pushes, ja das stimmt. Pepehands. Ja, ich hab's halt einfach nur für mich zusammengebastelt.
Tja, der Danny hat ja seine Motivation jetzt mit Streaming und Zeug wiedergefunden. Also
bei mir ist es halt so, ich hab für YouTube aktuell echt kaum Motivation. Mein letztes
YouTube-Video ist zwei Monate her und ich hab extra in dem Video erzählt, so nach dem Motto,
ja, wir können neue Clips einschicken und dann hab ich vielleicht wieder Motivation,
hatte ich aber nicht, hatte ich nicht. Dafür muss man echt sagen, in letzter Zeit Chat,
der Chat ist mein Zeuge, ja. In letzter Zeit auf Twitch war ich echt relativ oft am Start.
Euch mal an hier, alle paar Tage mal, da kann man sich nicht beschweren. Streams in on fleek,
genau. Das ist immer Chebat. Wenn ich sag, bald kommen mehr Videos, dann ist das hier eindeutig.
Okay, also wir machen mal weiter. Wo ist das Internet Security-Video, welches? Welches? Ich
hab ein paar. Meinst du das hier? Ich glaub, meinst du das hier? Oder meinst du das mit der
Fritzbox? Das da? Eins davon wirst du wahrscheinlich meinen. Ich habe zu dem Thema schon ein paar Videos
gemacht. Zock, zock, also ab und zu mal vereinzelt. Warzone haben wir schon zweimal glaube ich gespielt
On stream ich ich komme ja auch selbst erst wieder rein ich habe ja im vergleich zu den meisten anderen ich habe erst vor drei wochen zwei oder vor zwei wochen
Zwei oder drei wochen erst wieder angefangen war son zu spielen und ich habe vorher aus ein bisschen per so weg sei
Quasi drei jahre auf pc nix gespielt
Und so langsam aber sicher läuft's wieder
Weil es jetzt nicht so dass das jedes game den win ist
Allerdings zumindest fast jedes game top 10
Und auch ein paar wins
Verwendest du eigentlich Wim oder Emacs wenn du auf linux arbeitest ja ich verwende ich verwende zum größten teil Wim wenn ich auf der
Kommando zeile was mache
Aber hauptsächlich halt wenn ich mich auf server einlogger auf der kommando zeile was macht
Emacs habe ich zwar verwendet verwende ich nicht mehr meistens verwende ich mittlerweile nur linux tatsächlich visual studio code mittlerweile
Ich habe gedacht man fragen logging tool ist abgekackt aber ist nicht abgekackt
So
Aber
Ja Wim kann man prinzipiell nur empfehlen zu lernen wenn man auch ein bisschen remote of serveren unterwegs ist
Ja el mostafa so sieht es aus manche sachen merkt man sich einfach aus auswendig so wir machen wir weiter
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Wir können den sound von firefox einstellen nur mal zum beweis dass das ganze funktioniert
Weil ich so nicht gesehen habe so
firefox sound steht aktuell auf one drive
also one drive geh weg
Also firefox steht aktuell auf 15 15 prozent gesamtvolume
Aber wenn ich das ausführe dann steht firefox danach auf
30 prozent gesamtvolume
Hotkey guide please
Hä? Für was?
Für was hotkeys?
Manchmal wäre ich aus dem twitch chat echt nicht schlauer
So ich muss mich gerade mal konzentrieren wo sind wir stehen geblieben big brain moment
Chat wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Knäher bär wie machst du das mit dem instant voll im fullscreen einfach desktop wechseln
Knäher bär du bist doch so oft dabei was ist doch schon oft gesehen
Die einpländung die einpländung funktionieren gar nicht über irgendwelche obr
Geschichten das ist was was ich selbst programmiert habe ich kann es zwar auch mit hotkeys machen
Aber ich mache das meiste über den zweiten browser mit dem web interface ja
Dem web interface ja omega low easy as fuck get rekt
Ach bei dir geht das nicht vor mw15 ich glaube ich habe auch noch vor mw14 oder was habe ich
15 tatsächlich ok ja da weiß ich auch nicht warum es nicht funktioniert
Babykeks das wird sie nix das hat auch nicht geben
Ja hier wie saß dings hier schallchen wie sah es dann eigentlich aus
Also hast du das jetzt schon geschickt oder oder nicht habe ich vielleicht übersehen
Chat wo sind wir stehen geblieben jetzt
Ach ja ich weiß wieder ich weiß wieder was wir machen wollen genau also wir haben es jetzt ja geschafft den firefox auf 15 prozent volume zu setzen
Bei der gelegenheit können wir gleich mal ausprobieren ob das mit modern warfare auch funktioniert
Das testen wir noch mal ob das mit modern warfare auch funktioniert da sehen wir überhaupt ob da kram
Theoretisch möglich ist was ich hier vor habe
Ja crashy fluffy genau das wollten wir machen main audio auslesen
Wir lassen es einfach im hintergrund laufen
Genau wir lassen es einfach im hintergrund laufen und gucken jetzt mal ob wir den prozess überhaupt hier auslesen können
Modern warfare so heißt es prozess id 167 8 8 easy
So das heißt wir stellen es mir modern
Wie wie schreiben das modern warfare zusammen hat man das geschrieben so von der idee her modern warfare stellt sich ja immer auf 100 prozent
Sollte modern warfare jetzt sich auf die hälfte stellen
Wenn das funktioniert
Funktioniert aber nicht
exzellent
Warum von der Idee her ist es immer auf 100 prozent
Funktioniert aber nicht exzellent warum funktioniert es nicht
Vielleicht weil das hier gar nicht greift man breakpoint hin
Geht auch greift
Es heißt gar nicht modern warfare es hat sich beendet
Warum hat sich das kann es sein dass das game denkt es ist ein cheat was ich laufen habe
Das wäre natürlich ziemlich monka es wenn es das denkt
Anti cheat wenn es jetzt echt anti cheat ist und das nicht funktioniert
Dann ist es ein cheat was ich laufen habe
Das wäre natürlich ziemlich monka es wenn es das denkt
Anti cheat ey wenn es jetzt echt anti cheat ist und das nicht funktioniert
Safe mode no
Wack wack
Direkt in die hälfte
Direkt in die hälfte direkt in die hälfte direkt in die hälfte
Okay mal gucken mal gucken ob ich mal gucken ob das wirklich als anti cheat erkennt
Da bin ich echt gespannt erkennt es als anti cheat
Oder aber es funktioniert nicht
Aber es funktioniert nicht
Warum funktioniert das nicht was ist das denn für ein schwachsinn ok wir setzen auf null
set volume
Ach so es funktioniert nicht weil ich es hardcoded setze
Null
Battlefield 3 war deine zeit euer battlefield 3 das stimmt battlefield 3 war echt
Ziemlich nice es soll ja demnächst in remaster kommen
Aber ich bin immer noch der ansicht battlefield 3 braucht kein remaster
Nach battlefield 3 hatte ich ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr so viel bock das stimmt
So mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert hat jetzt geht's kommt mal jetzt haben wir den sound ausgeschaltet
So jetzt jetzt schalten wir den sound auf 50 prozent von modern warfare
Ja funktioniert auch ok alles gut funktioniert doch man muss es man muss es bloß richtig machen dann funktioniert es auch
Blut
Man muss es nur richtig machen
so 0.1
So und jetzt sollte modern warfare ganz leise eingestellt sein
Set volume was macht das da
Null jetzt sollte der sound aus sein wenn es funktioniert
Ach das game ist wieder
What the fuck?
Kann das sein
Kann das sein dass das game sich allgemein beendet oder ist das wirklich eine anti cheat geschichte warum sich das beendet
Das anti cheat hat das game eine lock glaubst du selbst nicht dass das ein lock hat
Meint ihr das ist eine anti cheat oder das game spackt einfach nur rum
Ich habe die idee wir gehen einfach wir gehen einfach mal in
In privates match rein und lassen das laufen und dann gucken wir ob es abstürzt wir machen einfach privates match und gucken ob es abkackt
Wo macht man die ordnung
lene
Ja es gut
Custom Game Genau das, das wollte ich schon immer spielen
Team Deathmatch Hackney hat alle eine, exellent Ok, das Game ist ziemlich laut, wie man vielleicht
hört und jetzt müsste der Sound vom Game eigentlich ausgeschaltet werden
Ok, mal gucken ob das ausgeschaltet wird Sound aus und Game läuft noch
Ja Flo96 man weiß, weiß nie
Alter, das ist Anti-Cheat
Ich glaub's nicht Alter, das Game erkennt das als Anti-Cheat, wollt ihr mich verarschen
Das Game ist so kaputt, dass die Audio-Settings total abgefuckt sind und nicht
funktionieren und da kann ich es noch nicht mal selber fixen oder was
Was ist das für ein Scheiß
Warum Infinity Ward, warum, wahrscheinlich bin ich jetzt auch gleich noch gebannt oder so was
Vielleicht sollte ich das besser lassen
Nein
Die sehen, dass du irgendwas mit dem Process machst, ja wahrscheinlich sehen die das
Doch T-Bulus, das geht auch
Wobei das teilweise auch broken ist, weil das nicht abhängig zur Master Volume Lautstärke
ist die In-Game-Settings und Mines ist abhängig zur Master Volume Lautstärke
Wir machen, wir machen Fullscreen Border lass mal
Multiplayer Private Match
Vielleicht schalten wir es mal nicht aus, sondern machen es auf 1 oder 05
Infinity Ward is watching you, ja anscheinend
Okay mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert
Ja hat funktioniert
Mixer, es hat auch gesetzt auf 15%
Setzen wir uns auf 100%
Hat auch funktioniert
Lag das daran, dass das Game Fullscreen ist vielleicht
Lag das daran, dass das Game Fullscreen ist, ich meine auszuschließen ist bei dem Spiel
nichts
Ihr hört das Sound, das Sound, ne
Ich kann, oder es liegt daran, dass ich den Sound nicht auf 0 setzen darf, das kann auch
sein
Sound auf, wieso, jetzt crashts nicht
Sound auf 0, Sound auf 1
Gleich wird D-Ranked
Also das funktioniert, Lautstärke, Setzen vom Spiel klappt
Ja, okay, das lag an Fullscreen
Das lag an Fullscreen
Erstmal ne Runde hier
Ja, passt
Warum lag das am Fullscreen, das Game versteht echt keiner
Okay, also sprich Soundsettings einstellen funktioniert, aber ohne Fullscreen-Spiele
sacken doch
Ja frag mich nicht warum es nicht funktioniert, ich kann ja auch nichts dran ändern, ich hab
den Kram ja nicht programmiert hier
Ich frag mich eh warum das Game 200GB groß sein muss, aber das ist alles das Thema
Warum ist die Bahn zu spät, warum ist Modern Warfare so groß, 2 Sachen die werden wir nie
ergründen können
Gleich ist D-Ranked, ja, gleich, gleich, gleich bin ich wirklich D-Ranked
Erster Strike, danach Account weg
Okay, also Leute, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, also wir setzen das Volume von Modern Warfare,
das funktioniert
Da bin ich schon mal zufrieden, dass das funktioniert
So, und die Sache ist die, jetzt kommt Trick 17
Das Problem ist jetzt, dass ich Modern Warfare will ich auf 13 setzen
Das ist ich 13 von meiner Gesamtlautstärke
Das ist so die Standardlautstärke, die ich immer hab und das ist in dem Spiel laut genug
13% Gesamtlautstärke bei ca. 30% Gesamtsound, also das Spiel ist fucking laut
Oder du bist auf Twitch gebannt, weil du cheats für ein Spielcode ist
Oi, ja, das wär richtig, oi
Klärbär, warum hast du eigentlich kein Abo, ist das ausgelaufen
Was, Klärbär, du bist so oft da, so oft da und hast das Abo auslaufen lassen, ich gifte
dir eins
Geschenk Abo verteilen
Pogos, so muss das sein
5 Monate, huge
Ja, du bist so oft bei, ich seh dich so oft auch im Chat aktiv und sowas
Da muss das mal sein, ja
Das beste ist, ich krieg davon 2,50 Euro wieder, also mich kostet das Abo eigentlich
plus 2,50, also im Prinzip bezahle ich Twitch dafür, dass ich dir ein Abo schenken darf
Wenn man es mal genau nimmt, also eigentlich geb ich Twitch Geld, dass ich dir ein Abo
schenke
Das ist eigentlich total wir, wenn man sich mal überlegt, total verkehrte Welt, ja
So, also, wie gesagt, das Problem ist jetzt, dass ich Modern Warfare auf 13% einstellen
will, allerdings 13% von der Gesamtlautstärke und ich über die Windows API plus prozentual
zur aktuellen Master-Lautstärke setzen kann, deswegen müssen wir jetzt absolut next level
big brain shit machen
Hier bekommen wir raus, Moment, wo waren wir, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, das ist so hässlich
Hier bekommen wir raus, auf welchem Level mein Mastervolum steht, mein Mastervolum steht
auf 30%, das stimmt auch hier, Mastervolum, sieht man hier, Mastervolum steht auf 30%,
das heißt, ich muss jetzt ausrechnen, wie viel bei 30% Mastervolum 13% von 100% Gesamtlautstärke
sind
Quickmaps, wer weiß, wie es geht
Lusus97, Twitch Prime, excellent subscription, danke schön, Massive IQ für den Chat wieder,
Massive IQ Boost, die Stonks, die IQ Stonks gehen hoch, Dreisatz, nee, so einfach ist
an der Stelle nicht
Pokemon Soundtrack, ja
Ich hoffe, das Game läuft nicht ab, das soll weiter laufen im Hintergrund
Also, ich hab so eine grobe Idee, wie man das eventuell machen könnte
Also, wir haben, wir haben 30% Gesamtvolum, ich muss mir das nochmal anzeigen lassen,
wir machen jetzt was anderes, ich stell das jetzt auf 15%, das ist die Hälfte, so wir
wissen, dass wir 30% Gesamtvolum haben, so 50%, ok, 50% von, es hat sich wieder beendet,
oh man, scheiß Game, Alter, das ist Anti-Cheat-Erkennung, fuck, das sackt, warum erkennen die sowas
als Anti-Cheat, die sollen mich in Ruhe lassen oder ihr Game ordentlich programmieren, dann
muss ichs nicht selber machen, wir machen das jetzt trotzdem, also, wir machen das mit
dem Firefox wieder, Firefox, weil der Firefox da crashed wenigstens nicht, also mein Ziel
ist es, den Firefox, oh, so, also jetzt die Lautstärke irgendwas hier verändert, ne,
ne, also, mein Ziel ist es, den Firefox auf, sagen wir mal, 13% einzustellen, also sprich,
wir haben 30% Gesamtvolum, 30%, ok, das les ich dann, das hardcronen wir jetzt mal und
sagen, hier, Mastervolum ist 30%, ok, so, das heißt, wenn das Mastervolum 30% ist, oder
sagen wir mal 15%, ne, also, was ich ausrechnen will, ist folgendes, es sind 15%, es sind
15% von 100% maximaler Lautstärke, wie der Firefox eingestellt ist vom Maximalvolum,
allerdings muss ich jetzt wissen, wieviel 15% maximaler Lautstärke in Prozent sind
von 30% des Ganzen, also 50, im Prinzip soll da sowas wie 50 oder so rauskommen, so, also,
muss ich sagen, 30, 13 mal 100 minus Master, oh, das ist exzellent, quick maths, also,
ich würd sagen, wir können sowas hier machen, wo sind wir denn, Mastervolum, hardcronen wir
mal, also, ich würd sagen, wir machen sowas wie 30 durch, big brain, 30 durch und dann
das aktuelle Volum, und dann gucken wir mal, ob das stimmt, also, von der Idee her, sollte
er mir jetzt ausgeben, 50, ne, sollte er mir ausgeben, 15, stimmt das, ne, ne, das stimmt
nicht, was ich da gemacht hab, aber ich hab mich auch verschieben, ich soll da Master
nicht voll, Master muss da rein, 3, 3, ah, ist das vielleicht kein float, 3, wait a minute,
ist das verkehrt, was ich da mache, ich bin zu low brain dafür, quick maths, ah, 3, ja
richtig, lull, ich darf den ja auch nicht setzen, den Kram, alter, ich bin ja auch bescheuert,
guck mal, ja, 15, das stimmt, ist richtig, was ich gemacht hab, 15, guckt hier, 15,
sehr gut, big, big brain, quick maths, also, gut, wir wissen jetzt, dass wir 15, 15% big
brain, ja, was face reveal bei einer Million Abos hab ich da grad so durch den Chat durchgehen
sehen, Max steht das noch mit dem face reveal bei einer Million Abonnenten auf YouTube, ja,
aber nachdem ich keine Videos mache auf YouTube werde ich auch nie eine Million Abos bekommen
oder willst du jetzt den followbot anschmeißen, legit subscriber natürlich, legit subscriber
und nicht irgendwie so blödsinn da, auf Twitch eine Million, ja, dann, dann ist, dann mach
ich double face reveal, wenn ich auf Twitch eine Million hab, dann mach ich face und foos
reveal in einem Video, damit alles revealed, alter, ähm, übrigens, mir ist gerade eingefallen,
es ist total blödsinn, was ich hier ausrechne, was soll ich eigentlich mit den 15% haben,
was will ich damit eigentlich, master mal wohl, ist das wirklich so, man darf nicht
vergessen, das sind alles irgendwelche float Geschichten, was, ah, excellent, siehst du,
der Chat ist, der Chat ist halt einfach high IQ, ja, ist eigentlich auch viel logischer,
virgin check, Poki W, oh, oh, oh, oh, das ist eine schlechte Idee, Pekaknostik, ich mach
mal mit, das ist eine schlechte Idee, ganz schlechte Idee, oh Leute, ich bin voll brain
afk gerade, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich jetzt machen wollte, ähm, ich will setzen, ach,
scheiß drauf, es funktioniert doch eh nicht, weil modern warfar den Kack als cheat erkennt,
das ist so fail, alter, dieses Kackgame, warum erkennt es das als cheats, das ist, das ist,
ah, au, jetzt hab ich auch noch Adinaska an der Stelle, wo ich blauen Fleck hab, ah,
Pepehands hier, ach, das ist doch Müll, warum geht das mit dem Game nicht, das ärgert
mich jetzt, das funktioniert, das funktioniert so gut, ja, das funktioniert so gut, ich meine,
es sieht mega hässlich aus, aber es ist halt, Windows-APD ist halt mega hässlich, aber
es geht nicht, weil das Spiel es als Anti-Cheat erkennt, mach doch mal einen eigenen Linux
Rise, mein i3 ist gerised genug, der reicht, der ist so gerised, mein i3, da kann es ja
kaum noch mehr, mehr reißen, ja, ja, aber richtig, jetzt wissen wir wenigstens, wie
die Windows-APD funktioniert, die Windows-Audio-APD, ja, Windows-Audio-APD braucht man immer,
kannst du jetzt direkt in deinen Lebenslauf reinschreiben, ich hab den Stream von Max
zur Windows-Audio-APD geguckt, feelsbadman, das ärgert mich richtig, dass das Spiel das
als Cheat erkennt, Kack-Game, alter, Wood-Face, ich meine, man könnte das bestimmt noch
ein bisschen trickreicher machen, indem man verschleiert, was die Anwendung im Hintergrund
treibt oder so, aber die werden schon den Grund haben, warum sie sowas als Anti-Cheat
erkennen, oder nee, umgedreht, die haben keinen Grund, warum sie sowas als Anti-Cheat erkennen,
die haben ja Anti-Cheat halt so gebaut, dass das mit reinfällt, kannst du mir eventuell
beim Wechsel einer Schriftart helfen für i3, ja, kann ich Sebaro, das ist ganz einfach,
Schriftart wechseln in i3 macht man so, Font, so, easy, das war's, mehr muss man nicht machen,
machen ein Bug-Report, genau, also, wo kann man Modern Warfare Bug-Reports, geht das überhaupt,
Bug-Reporting, was ist denn das für eine hässliche Seite, Igitt, hast du gelesen, was ich geschrieben
habe, nee, hast du Ed Wupplos davor geschrieben, da wird's bei mir nämlich hervorgehoben,
was hast du denn geschrieben, ah, hier, es wird, aber komischerweise nur ab und zu erkannt
oder wenn die App etwas länger läuft, probier doch mal schnell zu setzen, um die App zu
beenden, die App beende sich direkt wieder, die App beende sich direkt wieder, ich denke
auch, dass sie nur testweise kurz immer gucken, wenn was ist, aber es ist halt nicht reproduzierbar,
100 Cent, exellent, Bits, die Seite ist mal richtig hässlich zum Bug-Reporten, was haben
sie sich da überlegt bei Activision, sie sieht aus wie eine Seite, die der Praktikant
in der Mittagspause auf dem Klo zusammen gewusstet hat, ey, was ist das hier, und es liegt nicht
an meinem Darkreader, weil mein Darkreader ist aus, und ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn
ich meinen Darkreader anmache, sieht die Seite sogar mit Darkreader besser aus, die Seite
sieht mit Darkreader besser aus als im Originalen, guckt euch das mal an, so lächerlich, oder,
die Seite mit Darkreader sieht besser aus als die Originalseite, na toll, habt ihr gut
gemacht Activision, perfekt, der Knäherbär, ja ich sehe jetzt keinen Sinn drin, den Dacrosse
da nicht weiterzumachen, wenn es mit Modern Warfare eh nicht geht, das ist echt kacke,
ihr Trumpet, können wir mal ausprobieren, ob es das kann, aber wahrscheinlich kann
es das auch nicht, ihr Trumpet, get, dass sie mich immer dazu verleiten wollen mich zu
registrieren, welcome to your Trumpet, ja, Volumixer, oh, what the, was zum geil ist das
für eine Anwendung, what the fuck, was ist das, wollen die mich verarschen, Massive Quality
Software, das ist übrigens falsch, das ist hier, das ist richtig, das ist richtig hier,
gleich mal gucken ob es hier die Lautstärke Einstellung richtig macht, UVP Apps, ich glaube
das ist gar keine UVP App, das ist eher, das ist eher eine WPF, ok, schauen wir mal ob
das das kann, ich glaube nicht, dass es das hinbekommt, warum steht das jetzt auf 83,
ach so, weil es 83 von 30 sind, no, ah, MW 100%, ok, mal schauen, stellen wir es mal
auf 30% ein, wenn es mit ihr Trumpet geht, dann liegt das daran, dass sie das whitelisted
haben, ok, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob ihr Trumper das hinkriegt, aber anscheinend kann
man da eh nichts groß, Windows Legacy, ah, das ist der alte, ok, ok, die Anwendung gefällt
mir insofern schon mal, die ist aufs nötigste beschränkt, so schauen wir mal, ob es das
hinbekommt jetzt, ne 100%, kanns nicht, crap, kack Game, da brauche ich die Anwendung hier
auch nicht, wozu, ah, Exit, exellent, weg, wo ist das Door, Remove, ihr, ah, Anwendung,
weg, ehm, hallo, ich hab dich beendet Game, Spiel, falls du es nicht mitbekommen hast,
ich hab dich beendet, ja, ich denke auch, dass ich das anders machen müsste mit der Prozess
ID, als über den offensichtlichsten Weg, weil die halt sowas scannen werden, was richtig
bescheuert ist, Spiel, ich hab dich beendet, Spiel hat mehr Rechte, Spiel will sie nicht
beenden lassen, Spiel mag nicht, Spiel hat keinen Bock, ok, Warzone, Modern Warfare, wo
ist das Spiel, hier, bam, yes, ja wenigstens darf ich es über den Taskmanager beenden,
ich weiß auch nicht, was mit dem Gamechamp ist, Spielt Max jetzt Warzone, nö, Max geht
gleich wahrscheinlich, demnächst irgendwann auf, weil das was er vorher hatte nicht funktioniert
hat, weil das Spiel meine Software als Cheat erkennt, dabei sind wir gar nicht so die
richtigen Hacker-Mans und haben Cheats gebastelt, wir wollten einfach nur die Lautstärke von
Modern Warfare anpassen, sonst nix, einfach nur die Lautstärke anpassen, aber das ist
nicht erlaubt, Cheat baited, ja, P-Poset, P-Poset, das brauch ich noch als Bild, das
ist ganz wichtig, das hab ich noch gar nicht drinne, P-Poset, aber als, braucht das als
Parents, P-Poset.
So, safe, P-Poset, P-Poset.
So, ja Leute, leider funktioniert es nicht, ich kann da nichts ändern, sagt, wobei der
P-Poset gefällt mir nicht, da müssen wir einen anderen suchen, P-Poset, was mit dem
hier, oder mit dem hier, der ist besser, der gefällt mir besser, P-Poset 2, der gefällt
mir besser, P-Poset 2, ja, exzellent, schön, niedrige Auflösung, dass man nix erkennt,
so muss das sein, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, alles zu, alles dicht,
hier noch ein P-Poset, aber haben wir noch kein P-Poset drin, den brauchen wir unbedingt
noch, P-Poset, ganz wichtig, exzellent, der ist P-Poset, ja, perfekt, den brauchen wir
nur noch, P-Poset, P-Pofet, jetzt haben wir sie alle, irgendwas hat sich ja mein Audio
settings geändert, ok Leute, ja leider konnten wir nicht das machen, was wir machen wollten,
weil Modern Warfare keinen Bock hat, gut, gibt es irgendjemanden, den ich hausten kann,
zeig ich mal, ja, irgendjemand, der es gebrauchen kann, durchsuchen, du folgst, irgendjemand,
der es gebrauchen kann, der nicht so viele hat, oh, nee, es hat glaube ich keiner on,
naja, wurscht, ja, hat nicht so funktioniert, wie ich mir das ganze vorgestellt habe, ich
gehe jetzt erstmal auf, vielleicht spiele ich nachher noch eine Runde Bosser und das
kann sein, aber rechnet man eher nicht mit, müssen wir mal schauen, also Leute, bis dann,
machts gut, C U.